la finlande et la suède demande à
rentrer dans l'otan voici pourquoi c'est
une décision historique un peu comme la
suisse la finlande et la suède sont
traditionnellement neutres mais avec
l'invasion de l'ukraine les deux pays
situé près de la rue s'ils craignent
pour leur sécurité il souhaite donc
rejoindre l'alliance militaire de l'otan
dont font notamment partie les
etats-unis la france et le royaume uni
car concrètement si un membre de l'otan
est attaqué tous les autres membres
doivent le défendre la suède et la
finlande espère donc bénéficier de cette
protection en cas d' attaques russes
c'est justement en grande partie parce
que l'ukraine veut rejoindre l'otan que
la russie a décidé de l'envahir vladimir
poutine considère en effet que cette
alliance militaire est une menace pour
la russie si la finlande rentrer dans
l'otan la longueur des frontières
terrestres que l'organisation partage
avec la russie doublerait en passant
d'environ 1200 kilomètres à plus de 2500
vladimir poutine a assuré que
l'élargissement de l'otan provoquera des
réponses de la part de la russie